Hernan Gomez with the cap back out and
he got that technical so early in the
game there's chairman Walker triple-core
number 15 and his team really went south
and started mike connelly got hurt for
the year they just could not get
anything going
gamba went through Kaminsky and Marvin
Williams
[Applause]
timba has been money here the first
that's his third trip opportunity now
for Malik into Wayne's also freight to
play with a couple of starters make sure
that they stay organized that they play
good basketball underneath four minutes
to play here in our first half
Billy her name Gomes back in for the
Hornets
[Applause]
first half Tribble Kimba has Brooks on
it to the floor heat chip top of the key
got three and a quarter I'm gonna share
you mom look right nice move without the
basketball I just want to show you one
it counts as three for one Eric Conn's
let it stop perfect presentation it down
Warren it's printing the other way let's
see if they go two for one come on
[Applause]
started from him a little bit short
rebounded earn a gold record right here
you know you're hot will you just stand
you just freeze the pause that's what
they call it pause white guard the
basketball or it's make it past ninety
five points that mean
for Papa John's triple record in triple
stumble lose your balance regain it and
put it in the air
look at
[Music]
joy